hello everyone and welcome back to the
world blitz championship it's around 6
and so far only Magnus Carlsen and his
15 year old opponent from Uzbekistan who
is also a grandmaster it's such a very
young age are five out of five and not
only that a blue Sitaram noted back
defeated some very strong opponent so
far he had only one feeding master and
four very very strong grandmasters he
defeated the young Indian Grandmaster
goo Cody he defeated Vladimir Pharaoh
save Ralph mom and off and you young G
and now faces Magnus Carlsen although
with the black piece so this is one of
the games I wanted to show you it just
finished and I like I said if I really
yeah I see one that that I love we're
going to show it and it's just a wild
one you know a three-minute games if you
have a weak heart this is this is a you
know very dangerous to watch but okay
without further ado Magnus opens with d4
we have Knight to f6 Knight to f3 east
six and Bishop to g5 magnet schools for
the Toray attack we have d5 by abuse a
tour of we're III and bush of the e7 c4
we have castles all standard developing
moves with Queen to c2 and now h6 not
allowing the age so important to remain
a target and the Magnus now trades and
we're Bishop captures Bishop captures
and pushes h4 in the future since this
White has the black has this light
square setup wants to play g4 and g5 we
have g6 by black anticipating this we
have Knight to c3 and now there is one
game where c6 was played and I believe
Wesley so lost the Sharma mid year over
the last year in the singles Cup with c5
but here of the so total goes Bishop to
g7 and it is a new move
so as of move 9 now we have a completely
new game Magnus castles Queen side so
castles of opposites opposite sides it
means it's going to be an attacking game
we're going to have a nice race c6
strengthening in the center and the now
Magnus starts the attack with g4 we had
Knight to d7
and now g5 so as Abdullah Toro was
expecting this now d h5 move comes we
have King to be won by Magnus and now
Queen to e7 continuing development
captures we have a cap for Sundy five
and now Bishop to d3 we have nice the b6
now freeing up the light square bishop
and now look back to c1 not allowing
this pin to come with with an attack on
the night which is undefended and also
the rook will be on d1 r+ later on the
rook will be used on c5 maybe to prevent
black from exit executing c5 we have the
ship the east six and now comes nice to
e2 here Magnus wants to bring this
Knight over to f4 and that's going to be
a very deadly night if this happened so
abdul Sattar of doesn't allow it Bishop
to g4 threatens the D undefended night
we have night 2 h2 and Nam our trades
Bishop captures we have Queen captures I
need to end the rook a to ca now with
ideas of pushing c5 but Magnus goes f4
and this is a this is a very committal
decision since f5 yes it's coming but
this really weakens your III point III
is now a backwards pawn and abdul Sattar
immediately goes after that point with
rook F to e8 with rook h t1 defending
and here Peter let go mentioned when he
saw this position that now would be
would be you know an excellent time to
push c5 and indeed c5 is the strongest
maneuver for black here because if
Magnus gets Knight f3 to e5 here it's
just a much better position for white so
here with this you pretty much open up
the position and you don't allow Magnus
to consolidate the e3 pawn will remain a
weakness but obviously thought of play
Knight to c4 instead he gave Magnus a
moment to catch his breath and now
Magnus just grabs the pawn Bishop
captures we have pawn captures Queen
captures here and now Quinta efore with
check abdul Sattar Oh probably wanted to
infiltrate with queen g2 but Magnus
doesn't move the King instead he blocks
with Queen to c2 now not allowing this
infiltrating move and okay Abu Sitaram
goes back and now causing his upper pond
he goes rook cd1 strengthens the
structure here and now prepares efore we
have rook seated d8 by abdul Sattar of
and now II for Queen back the e6 and now
again Carson has to decide how to
improve the position he's up upon
although his knight on h2 isn't all that
you know great of a piece and if you
start to bring it into too early then
you
I'll leave the defense of the G for
square the Queen Queen can infiltrate
this way and if you start with f5 right
away then
well black can just capture it and you
will have to go E 5 because if you
capture them just Queen chapters here is
a winning for black you have to block
with the Queen captures captures and
black is just the upper whole rook
so after Queen e6 we have Queen to F do
right
Magnus found this he'd spent some
seconds trying to find this move so
everything will be nicely defended and
now the rook on e1 is defended twice
he's preparing to push f5 we have looked
a d7 by abdul Sattar of with ideas of
doubling either on the E or the D file
depending on what's needed and now
Magnus just pushes f5 we have Quint
capturing doesn't really do anything is
just bust open and the King and King
Kings defenses so Queen to c4 and now f6
and now closing this the diagonal of
this dark square bishop it goes really a
long way for Carlson's position with
rush up to f8 and now Knight to f3 so
now if you know you're able to push a 5
and start those pawns going then white
will be practically winning we looked
the d6 by black not allowing 95 to come
with a fork so Knights the e5 not only
with an attack on the Queen Queen back
to e6 and here Knights to d3 with ideas
of knife the c5 but also f4 is an
excellent square for the knight so here
abdul Sattar of created a little trap
for magnus he played the Queen to g4 and
a magnus fell right into it he has to
play rook to e3 and everything is now
nicely defended and then a little by
little improve his position and continue
playing the game so this is what you
have to do even at the price of the h4
point but Magnus one for Knight to f4
instead which seems reasonable the h4
points still protected the knight really
blocking the Queen's influence in the
game but feel free to pause the video
and try to figure out what it is that
Magnus missed in this position well I
give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who were able to find find
that congratulations it is a clean pawn
and for those who just want to enjoy the
show it's rook captures on e4 yes even
Magnus can
something like this in a three-minute
blitz game our point is if you captured
the rook then queen cap for Sundy one is
mate
so of course Magnus was really really
sad that he missed this and he really
needed to you know recollect himself he
played rook to f1 but now Queen to f5
and now now it's actually black who's
better
we threatening a lot of nasty
discoveries here simply this would win
the Queen
I saw Kings the a1 and now c5 finally
the c5 move comes we have d5 by Magnus
creating the passed pawn but now c4
abuse a Toro wants to play c3 and bust
open cousins defenses with rogue DT one
trading off one of the attackers rook
captures we have Queen captures now
threatening some discoveries with maybe
Knight captures here since the rock
occupies the same file as the Queen but
now obviously thought of finds c3 and
here you don't have a chance for any
nasty discoveries if you play something
like this doesn't really do anything
since captures captures in the route b6
will be well not a six but rook to b6
check will be deadly after the King
moves Queen d3 and now if there's bishop
for example - FC 5 - d for now it's just
game over even even at the price of a
queen
so now after c3 Magnus decides to go for
Queen captures on c3 but now he just
gives up the d5 pawn with rook captures
on d5 now you cannot capture because
again you will get made it we have a
three by Magnus and now rook the c5
attacking the Queen Queen to d4 and now
rook the C to putting the rook into the
attack maybe if you can get something
like Queen to a5 a5 and maybe sacrifice
on a3 it's very unlikely because black
also has some problems with his King but
okay rook the d1 by Magnus and now look
back to see it not not allowing the
cousin to infiltrate
we have Knight to d5 now and again
Magnus grabs the steering wheel so the
same his Knight is now nicely
centralized much better than obvious a
Taurus Bishop we have looked eight now
Magnus takes this opportunity to grab
the a7 pawn we have Queen captures an a7
and now Queen to g4 with threats of
queen capture son on the one
so Magnus quickly rushes back Queen d4
now he's up upon and now if he's able to
trade everything the two-to-one
advantage on the Queen side should allow
him some good winning chances so we
looked for of course I'll do a tour of
the clients and now Knight to e7 check
here Magnus is hoping for Bishop
captures pawn captures and you will just
have to go for the pawn and I'll allow
white to do with the white pleases
because if you capture then check with
the Queen King g7 and now you just check
and pick up the rook
so 97 checkup DeSoto removes back King
h7 and now Queen d5 hoping for Queen
captures and f7 abdul Sattar of defense
with the rook of course he doesn't want
to trade Queens and now Queen d7
preparing to you cannot capture on b7
since your rook would be hanging so
Queen d7 preparing to move the knight in
the game capture on f7 but now Bishop
captures on e7 we have F captures an a7
and now abdul Sattar of just goes for
rook captures on e7
and now you don't really have a choice
here the the material on the board is
equal and both of them are extremely low
on time here Magnus allows the trade we
have rook captures Queen captures and d1
check King e2 and queen to d5 check and
it was in this position on mo 51 that
Magnus Carlsen and noted where abdul
Sattar of agreed to a draw so both of
them came into this matchup 5 out of 5
and now a nice draw for both of them 5
and a half out of 6 for both of them
exciting stuff first
another big blundered upon then Magnus
blundered upon and then well we have a
draw so really impressive impressive
play by another backer abdul Sattar oh
only 15 years old and you know well play
playing with Magnus like that really
just impressive stuff so like I said I
do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank dolly but we are playing for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon if another interesting game
arises we will definitely cover it so
thank you all I will see soon and have
an excellent rest of your Sunday